[Musique]
voir les enfants
que se passe-t-il je suis sûr que
nicolas et pimprenelle viennent de faire
une grosse bêtise tu ferais bien d'aller
voir ça de plus près une hausse toujours
preuve pas trop tu fonces ouhlala ouais
ouais bon le chef nounours tu n'as pas
beaucoup d'ordres ma petite échelle ou
te caches tu as le téléphone allô
[Musique]
bonjour mademoiselle vous désirez on
voudrait un monsieur qui collent les
carreaux cassez avait crié parce que
prônait la casse et la fne plongée pas
vrai c'est nicolas on joue au ballon
rond
ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai tout ce qu'il
vous faut
je vous envoie mon meilleur vitrier
totaux on peut entre eux qu'est ce que
c'est le vitrier attrait messieurs ne
dit rien
bonsoir jeunes hommes houssam ciel des
triais alors on l'a fait des bêtises tu
es mais c'est le carreau cassé
monsieur nicolas jeter vite ce morceau
de verre s'il vous plaît c'est très
dangereux il ne faut pas toucher du
verre cassé sa coupe et vous posez vous
blesser et quand tu te blesses tu
pleures bon c'est pas la peine de faire
un grand nettoyage
je l'enlève avec un chiffon comme ça je
ne me lève pas
[Musique]
je vois ce que c'est là vous ne pouvez
plus vous blesser encore un carreau
cassé la vitre de la détenue la
mitraillette et passe la détenue des
vitriers la mitraille et basse et 1
et voilà le dernier morceau la détenue
la vitrine et la distribuer qui passent
là d'étriller la vie triées lavées
triées bassée
merci monsieur un vitrier vous avez fait
du très beau travail
dorian ma petite dame d'orient mon petit
monsieur salut salle et les criées
oneux fou
on a plus a fait revenir la vraie vie
trier pour remplacer le chaos
ouais comme ça on pourra encore le cas
ce money nicolas bien peuvent grenelle
[Musique]
mon petit nicolas j'ai bien peur que si
tu casses un autre carreau il ne passera
plus de vitriers allons mon bon nounours
en route
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher le fuck de pau ball 2
[Musique]
à
en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]